das ist hans georg maas niemand in der
cdu polarisiert so sehr wie er seine
sätze seine thesen bergen enorme
sprengkraft zum beispiel diese aussage
ich bin vor 30 jahren nicht der cdu
beigetreten damit heute 1,8 millionen
araber nach deutschland kommen
das war 2009 10 inzwischen ist
hans-georg maßen bundestagskandidat der
cdu aufgestellt und zwar mit breiter
mehrheit von der cdu thüringen trotz
oder vielleicht sogar wegen seiner
bedenklichen aussagen das könnte jetzt
gefährlich werden für armin laschet auch
cdu und wenn es nach ihm und seiner
partei geht der nächste kanzler sein
parteifreund hans jörg maßen hat ihn
nämlich mal wieder gerade eine sehr
unangenehme debatte eingebracht und
streit in den eigenen reihen
dieser streit dreht sich um die frage
what happened to hans-georg massen ich
bin die qualität man willkommen bei uns
hat politik so hans gerd maßen sorgt
gerade mal wieder für mächtig mächtig
ärger und zwar in einer sehr hohen
preisklasse
es geht um diese aussage ich halte es
für ausgesprochen verwerflich und ich
halte es für eine schande dass die
aufsichtsbehörden die sind öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk nicht in der
hinsicht wirklich mal korrigieren wenn
man sieht dass es verbindungen gibt
zwischen der tagesschau oder zwischen
personen defender trittin und von
tagesschau arbeiten und der linken und
linksextremen szene
dann wäre das wirklich auch eine
untersuchung wert dass auch die
biografie von einigen redakteuren mal
auf den prüfstand gestellt wird ob diese
leute die charakterliche eigenschaft
haben auch in der tagesschau die
tagesschau durch redaktionen zu
begleiten
wenn uns test für die journalisten von
der tagesschau ein
untersuchungsausschuss der die
charakterliche eignung der ard kollegen
prüfen soll
weil das nach meinung von hans georg
maßen ein links 3 bei den
öffentlich-rechtlichen gibt ein cdu
politiker und ex präsident des
bundesamtes für verfassungsschutz setzt
ein fragezeichen hinter die
pressefreiheit die in artikel 5 des
grundgesetzes also der verfassung
garantiert wird steile these steilen
forderung steilvorlage der ärger
programmiert und erfolgte auf dem fuße
die ersten in der cdu äußerten sich
sauer so zum beispiel der chef der
fraktion im niedersächsischen landtag
der fordert ganz zeitgemäß maßen quasi
in eigenverantwortung zu etwas auf er
twitterte unsere schwäche freiheit ist
unantastbar
wer einen gesinnungstest für
journalisten fordert fällt in dunkelste
zeiten zurück das ist mit den werten der
cdu nicht vereinbar
hg maßen treten sie zurück und aus der
cdu aus andere arten maßen würde diesen
schritt wahrscheinlich nicht gehen und
gingen selber nämlich in ihren
forderungen einen schritt weiter für die
cdu deutschlands für die cdu
niedersachsen ist ganz klar wir grenzen
uns von allen tendenzen die nicht fest
auf unserem fundament nämlich unserem
grundgesetz und den werten der union
stehen ab wer diese nicht teilt muss als
kandidat erst gar nicht antreten und
dann gibt es noch die in der cdu die
finden maßen hat sich jetzt endgültig
ins aus geschossen
ich habe meine
empfohlen ein parteiausschlussverfahren
gegen ihn zu führen
ich weiß dass das möglicherweise lange
dauern kann aber dann wäre eben klar
position eben in der union keinen platz
mehr haben und das ist eben die
forderungen die ihr jetzt aufgestellt
hat gesinnungsprüfung journalistinnen
das ist eine drohkulisse die gegen die
pressefreiheit gerichtet ist sowas kann
es in der cdu nicht geben
und armin laschet selbst dieses bild
kursiert seit tagen im netz setzt euch
mal genau an
laschet ließ maßen äußerungen die ersten
tage nämlich öffentlich unkommentiert
bis zu seinem tag bei der brigitte
also wenn rechtliche gründe da sind dass
man jemand aus seiner partei
ausschließen kann und da ist die
schwelle sehr sehr hoch nach unserem
recht da muss man die nutzen
es gibt aber auch positionen die man
nicht teilt wo man eine andere meinung
hat und die muss man dann ab klar
benennen und für mich war immer klar das
war auch meine position im
innerparteilichen wettbewerb
wir müssen den kurs der mitte
beibehalten wir müssen uns klar nach
rechts abgrenzen
mit der afg wird nicht geredet nicht
koaliert nicht kooperiert gar nichts es
muss die klare linie sein und an die
muss sich jeder auch der 299
direktkandidaten also auch der erwähnte
halten
jetzt hat er einen etwas und ich habe
einfach nicht die absicht jetzt zu jeder
bemerkungen die er im laufe der nächsten
wochen macht jedes mal dass aufzuwerten
durch eine positionierung die ich selbst
dann dagegen heißt nicht unbedingt dass
sie es auf werten aber der vorgang ist
ja schon der dass das langsam zu einem
giftigen klima für er hat das am abend
revidiert und unsere haltung zum
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk um die
idee ist ja in diesem falle ja der die
ist glasklar das gemerkt den namen maßen
weiter lars hat nicht an dem unternehmen
nun es ist ja nicht so dass niemand den
ärger hätte kommen sehen und laschet und
auch die cdu in thüringen gewarnt hätte
dort in thüringen ist die afg und fabian
harke sehr erfolgreich gewesen zum
beispiel bei der letzten landtagswahl
also dachte sich ende april die dortige
cdu machen wir doch aus der not eine
tugend und stellen hans-gerd maßen als
direktkandidaten für die bundestagswahl
aus
[Applaus]
maaßen betonte in seiner bewerbungsrede
er sehe sich nicht als rechts ja auch
nicht mal als wirklich konservativ er
betrachte sich als ein realisten der
geerdet ist und nicht im elfenbeinturm
gebe und trete an um der afd stimmen
zustehen
diese frage wird ja seit langem nicht
nur in der cdu diskutiert was ist
eigentlich konservativ wie definiert er
das führt diese debatte doch mal unten
in den kommentaren
ich möchte mich auch gerne ein also
wurde hans-georg maßen direktkandidat
der cdu thüringen darüber haben sich
jetzt nicht alle in der cdu gefreut
serap köhler zum beispiel
cdu-politikerin in nordrhein westfalen
und das ist wichtig eine enge vertraute
von armin laschet gratulierte dem
thüringer verband jetzt nicht direkt zur
wahl masons übrigens mit 37 von 43
stimmen das sind satte 86 prozent der
lehrabgänger machte ihren unmut relativ
öffentlich und twitterte an die 730
parteikollegen in südthüringen
ihr habt echt den klein ich gehört wie
kann man so immer sein und die
christdemokratischen werte mal eben über
bord schmeißen
wer so große angst vor der afg hat hat
so fiel das längst aufgegeben ein
bitterer tag
nicolas zimmer ehemaliger fraktionschef
der cdu im berliner abgeordnetenhaus und
ex-staatssekretär hat die cdu deswegen
sogar verlassen
eine partei die maßen nominiert ist
nicht mehr meine so seine aussage
man hielt aber trotzdem weiter an dem
plan fest die afg womöglich zu bekämpfen
indem man hans-georg maßen gegen sie
ansetzt die afg zieht sich wie ein roter
faden durch die karriere des hans georg
maßen und diese karriere
die ist gar nicht mal so kurz und gar
nicht mal so schlecht
1978 trat hans georg massen in die cdu
ein
78 das ist mein geburtsjahr das ist 43
jahre her
das ist ganz schön lange zeit und
hans-georg maßen der war auch richtig
dass der präsident des bundesamtes für
verfassungsschutz
1991 begann maßen im
bundesinnenministerium
damals hieß der minister noch seit 16
minister blieb maßen in der behörde in
wechselnden positionen und machte sich
ein
guten namen dass das bundeskabinett in
2012 zum präsidenten des
bundesverfassungsschutzes machte von
2012 bis 2018 bei maßen dann also
präsident des bundesverfassungsschutzes
er schützte also unsere verfassung unser
grundgesetz vor deren feinden ein
wichtiger job unumstritten war er dabei
nie aber das ist in so einer position
auch quasi nicht möglich aber er genoss
hohes ansehen sonst hätte er diese
stelle auch sicherlich nicht sechs jahre
lang bekleidet da aber begann sein
abstieg und damit sind wir wieder bei
der afg maßen wurde nämlich als chef des
bundesverfassungsschutzes eine zu große
nähe zur fdp vorgeworfen er sei auf dem
rechten auge blind ist es teilweise
sogar und dann passierte chemnitz ende
august 2008 10 starb dort ein mann durch
messerstiche ein syrer und ein iraker
kamen in u haft
es folgten demos rechte aufmärsche
neonazis auf den straßen offen gezeigt
der hitlergruß sogenannte trauermärsche
auf einer dieser veranstaltungen gab es
hetzjagd gegen vermeintliche migranten
davon gibt es videos das einsätzen im
ganzen land war riesig
entsetzen auch bei mars allerdings nicht
weil er als verfassungsschutzchef
rassismus verurteilt musste sondern weil
es seiner meinung nach überhaupt keine
hetzjagd gegeben hatte und damit nicht
genug maßen ließ öffentlich einen hang
zu verschwörungstheorien erkennt und
sagte der bild nach einer vorsichtigen
bewertung sprechen gute gründe dafür
dass es sich um eine gezielte
falschinformation handelt um
möglicherweise die öffentlichkeit von
dem mord in chemnitz abzulenken ein
verfassungsschutzchef der offen
verschwörungstheorien verbreitet es
dauerte nicht lange da kamen die ersten
rücktrittsforderungen auf es folgte ein
riesiges hin und her in der grupo ein
riesiger streit in der gruppe oder diese
fast gesprengt hätte und dann aber doch
der rausschmiss von hans-georg maßen als
präsident des bundesamtes für
verfassungsschutz krasser abstieg lange
zeit hörte man von ihnen wenig noch
jetzt ist er wieder da als
direktkandidat der cdu in thüringen für
die bundestagswahl und erscheint auch zu
bleiben was auch bleibt sind drei fragen
erstens was sagt hans-georg maßen
eigentlich selber zu dem wirbel um seine
jüngsten äußerungen vor der kamera
nichts aber auch twitter hat er sich
geäußert
[Musik]
einen raushauen dann zurückrudern die
taktik kennen wir von populisten von
rechten parteien
und da kommt eventuell das kalkül der
cdu zum tragen denn die afg knöpft sich
den öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk
gerne und regelmäßig vor vielleicht holt
hans-georg maßen mit diesem manöver ein
paar wähler wieder zurück nur die frage
ist wie weit kann man da eigentlich
gehen dann kommt der punkt wo mögliche
koalitionspartner nach der
bundestagswahl wie zum beispiel die
grünen oder die spd sagen da können wir
nicht mitgehen frage nummer zwei warum
tut hans-georg maßen das alles
eigentlich ich glaube es gibt ganz
einfach im grünen der erste ist gekränkt
und beleidigt weil er nicht mehr
präsident des bundesverfassungsschutzes
swr ausgeflogen
zweitens er möchte recht behalten
in seinen ängsten um eine links
entwicklung der bundesrepublik und
drittens erwählt vor allen dingen
aufmerksamkeit
er provoziert damit die öffentlichkeit
seine eigene partei das ist es was ihn
antreibt frage nummer drei warum
schmeißt armin laschet hans-gerd massen
nicht raus warum schreibt er kein
parteiausschlussverfahren an
ich frage dazu jetzt soviel schönberger
die ist jurist denn berger was würden
sie armin laschet jetzt raten soll am
ersten rausschmeißen oder soll er in die
wahl behalten wie gefährlich ist das im
wahlkampf
politisch gesehen gibt zwei probleme zum
einen würde natürlich ein
parteiausschlussverfahren das thema
nochmal groß in die öffentlichkeit
bringen und konflikt noch mal groß in
die öffentlichkeit bringen andererseits
ist auch nicht auszuschließen dass sonst
weitere äußerungen im wahlkampf von
herrn maßen das thema in der
öffentlichkeit bleibt
darüber hinaus muss man sich natürlich
entscheiden bei einem solchen
parteiausschlussverfahren will man sich
politisch derart positionieren dass
solche positionen keinen platz in der
partei haben dass es nach original
politische entscheidung die man treffen
muss
und natürlich kann ist die überlegung
geben dass man möglicherweise damit
wähler hier wohl eher bäder
am rechten rand des politischen
spektrums verbrennt vielen dank das
schönberger
tja stadt sitzt also in der zwickmühle
was würdet ihr tun wenn ihr armin
laschet wert was würdet ihr ihm raten
oder anders gefragt worden
shit happens klassen wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann empfiehlt uns gerne
weiter abonniert unseren kanal coup die
sendung von meinen kollegen und schaltet
beim nächsten mal wieder ein danke und
tschüss